let's have a look at this first example
together
forces of magnitude five newtons seven
newtons and
some unknown number of newtons q newtons
act on a particle that is
in equilibrium so let's just underline
that that's important without that
we can't really go much further as shown
in the diagram below and then
the question is what's the magnitude of
q in newtons and you can see
we're not actually interested in the
particular value we just want to know
can we reason through what's going on
here
now even before you go anywhere right
just have a look at each of these
five potential solutions i hope you
recognize
even without knowing you know this
diagram you could actually just
look at these lines and you can
recognize these are all flowing out of
the cosine rule
right you've got an a squared plus b
squared minus two a b
cos c and the idea here is that there's
going to be the formation of a triangle
just like we did up above in here you
can see these three vectors here once i
put them together
i form a triangle and uh in that
triangle what i want to do is
find this unknown side q and that will
give me the magnitude
of that resultant force okay so how am i
going to do this
how do i create the appropriate triangle
well what i'm going to do is let me just
move this out of the way
so that i can draw a little more
accurately what i'm going to do is i'm
going to think about doing these vectors
one at a time and seeing what diagram
gets
created by that so if for instance i say
let's imagine doing this um this five
newtons
first okay that's my first vector i go
off in that direction and then the next
one i'm going to do
is this q vector i'm just going to go
clockwise okay
what result will i get well you can see
it's going to head up in the
north easterlyish direction i'm just
using that anguish so that it's it's
more accurate slightly than saying that
corner of the page
it's going to go upwards like this and
then
you can see i've positioned myself so
i'm sort of on this vertical because i
know the third and final vector
is going to be the 7 newtons which is
going downwards
so while i will measure this in or mark
this in as q
newtons i'm then going to finish it off
with this
which is 7 newtons
okay now you can see at this point i'm
going to use a i'm going to pull a
similar trick that i did in the
you know my previous easy examples here
which is that because i've got this
straight line here this is one long
vertical line i can take advantage of
the fact that these angles along here
have to add up
to 180 degrees so that gives me 70
degrees
on the inside here and i'm pretty much
done at this point right i'm trying to
find
q that's the unknown so 5 squared plus 7
squared
minus 2 times 5 times 7
cos of 70 degrees so when i have a look
at my answers here
you can see i can exclude b and
c and e they don't have the appropriate
angle
between a and d which is the right one
well that relationship that i just
mentioned before
using the cosine rule if i just write it
up here it's c squared
equals a squared plus b squared minus
two a b
cos c i always like to think of it as
pythagoras theorem
on steroids this is just the adjustment
factor for if your angle is not pi on
two
but you can see this as stated right the
cosine rule and pythagoras theorem they
don't give you the length of the side
directly
they give you the square of that side so
you've got this c squared here
if what i want is not q squared but q
then i need to take the square root of
both sides and that's going to give me
option a so that's how i reasoned
through this
hope that makes sense this is a very
simple example let's now push on this a
little further
when you've got concurrent forces that
uh you know i'm going to need to resolve
the horizontal and vertical components
so have a look at this one
with me this is a victor from revitorian
paper it says a flower pot of mass
m kilograms let's just underline that is
held in equilibrium by two
light ropes and i don't know if you have
seen this before but when they talk
about a light
rope all they mean is that the ropes
don't have any weight that we need to
worry about any significant mass
that's going to affect um you know you
know you actually have to
hold up your own mass you know you need
to have a substance strong enough to do
that
but we're just actually saying don't
worry about the rope we're just going to
think about the flower pots mass which
is
m kilograms both of which are connected
to a ceiling as you can see up here
they're sort of strung up and here's our
horizontal ceiling bar
the first rope makes an angle of 30
degrees to the vertical which you can
see here and
it's got a tension of t1 newtons okay so
let's mark that
in i'm going to make this a bit thinner
so this is the first rope here we know
it's the first one because it's got that
30 degree
angle and i'm going to call that t1
newtons going off in that direction
direction the second makes an angle of
60 degrees to the vertical
and has a tension of t2
newtons okay so let's have that one
going off in that direction and we'll
call this one
t two all right show that
t2 equals t1 on root three all right so
let's think about this for a second
what we want to try and do here is show
the relationship between these two ropes
and show that there's this kind of
proportional relationship going on here
now how am i going to do that well
there's a bunch of different things that
i need to
sort of take into account here but the
thing that's most obvious is
that because you've got this flower pot
and it's got its mass
of m kilograms right it's pulling
downwards
it's in equilibrium so we know it's not
pulling so hard that it's you know
exceeded the tension of the ropes that's
holding it up
but i know that there's going to be sort
of upward forces from
the ropes that are offset against the
mass of the flower pot now while that's
true you can see in part a this equation
here has nothing to do
with the mass of the flower pot it's
independent of
m so therefore in order to show that
this is true
the up down of this situation is not
going to be
relevant because if i'm thinking about
it vertically i have to bring in the
mass of the flower pot
what i'm going to do instead is think
about it horizontally
you can see it's not as though the one
of these ropes is pulling successfully
more than the other one
because like i said it's in equilibrium
so therefore
the horizontal components or the
horizontal forces
that are resulting from each of these
two ribs they also have to be
in balance so there's a lot to take in
there let me see if i can put some
things onto the diagram that's going to
help us make sense of it
this t1 here which is heading off at 30
degrees to the vertical right
i'm going to break it up i'm going to
resolve its forces into two components
there's this vertical component like so
and then this horizontal one like so
and the same thing happens for the
second row which has a tension of t2 so
it's got a vertical
just going to put this on the side just
so you can see them separately and then
it's also got a
horizontal like so now the whole idea
here is
you can see because it's in equilibrium
these two different forces even though
the diagram doesn't look like it they
have to be equal
to each other because otherwise this
thing would be swinging one way or the
other so therefore i just need to find
an expression for this
and an expression for this show that
they're equal and i should be able to
get this relationship
out here so to sort of you know put some
helpful names on things i'm going to
call this let's start with the first row
i'm going to call this x1 and y1
x being horizontal y being vertical and
just while i'm at it i'll do the same
for the other two
so i'll have this as x2 and i'll call
the other one y2
all right now if you have a think about
this diagram here for example if i
extend this vertical
downwards you've got this right angle
triangle happening
and of course the right angle triangle
is there because i'm putting in
horizontals
and verticals now if i have a look at
the relationship between
this horizontal line and this hypotenuse
here with the angle
that 30 degrees is up in the top corner
so this is opposite
on hypotenuse so it's sign that relates
these right so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to say well this is part a
i'll put this in red since i'm thinking
about this red triangle up here
i can say sine 30 equals
opposite which is x1 on hypotenuse which
is
t1 so now i have an expression for x1
it's going to be t1 times sine 30 but of
course
sine 30 is a half so it just gives me t1
on 2. i can do
i can make the same kind of i can pull
the same kind of trick over here on the
other
triangle you can see over here or the
other rope i should say
i can create a triangle here in much the
same way by
going and dropping this vertical all the
way there i've got this
right angle and so um x2 maybe if i move
this over just to make it a bit more
obvious that it's this
only down here in the same way it's
going to be opposite on hypotenuse it's
just that it's a different angle it's 60
degrees
right so therefore i'm going to say sine
of 60 degrees
equals opposite on hypotenuse which is
x2
on t2 in this case making x
to the subject i'll multiply t2 to the
other side
and i can also evaluate sine 60 degrees
which is
root 3 on 2. so that gives me root 3 on
2 t 2.
okay at this point here i know these two
things are in balance so i'm going to
say
since flowerpot is in equilibrium i
think this sort of verbal
reasoning is really really important not
to skip over
since it is in equilibrium
i can equate these horizontal forces
because they're opposing to each other
i can say x1 equals x2
in fact looking at the way they've
stated the question in in part a i'm
going to go one better and i'm going to
say
x2 equals x1
because i do want t2 as the subject so
it's going to be
root 3 on 2 t2
equals t1 on 2. so i hope that you can
see
this is where i got that um that result
from over there and i'm doing the same
thing
for t1 onto because i got it from over
here
and there's really just one line of
working required to get to it's not even
a line of working i'm just going to
write down the given result
i'm multiplying both sides by 2 which
cancels out 2 denominators down here and
then i'm dividing by root 3. so that
gives me
as required t2 equals t1 on
root 3. and
that's part a